bonjour à tous Le Sénat inflige un
double camouflé au gouvernement en
rejetant les deux mesures phares du
projet de loi de réforme des
collectivités territoriales hier
après-midi le Sénat a rejeté l'article
clé sur la répartition des compétences
cet article visait à supprimer la clause
de compétence général cette clause
permet aux collectivités de s'emparer de
domaines qui ne sont pas forcément de
leur ressort puis dans la nuit le Sénat
a rejeté le mode d'élection du
conseiller territorial les centristes
clé du scrutin ici au Sénat ont mené une
opposition farouche contre la
proposition du gouvernement de scrutin
uninominal à deux tours les centristes
exigaient eux l'introduction d'une dose
de proportionnelle le Sénat a donc
exprimé son vif mécontentement il faut
dire que ces deux propositions clés
devaient à l'origine faire l'objet de
projet de loi ultérieur elles ont
finalement été introduites par
l'Assemblée nationale empêchant ainsi le
Sénat de les examiner en première
lecture ce qui n'a pas forcément plus au
sénateurs tout de suite direction
l'émicycle poursivre ces débats autour
du mode d'élection du conseiller
territorial très bonne séance nous
reprenons la discussion en 2è lecture de
notre projet de loi modifié par
l'Assemblée nationale de réforme des
collectivités territoriales nous en
sommes parvenus aux articles 1er du
titre 1ier précédemment
réservé avant l'article 1er nous avons
un amendement numéro 82 c'est madame la
Présidente ah pardon monsieur rotill
pour Rael au règlement et ensuite madame
simplement pour préciser un vote puisque
sur l'amendement 558 je souhaitait le
voter et le vote se retrouve négatif
c'est une précision que je souhaitais
apporter C pour moi-même et aussi pour
mon collègue Philippe Darniche pour
qu'elle soit inscrite au Journal
officiel bien il en sera ainsi décidé
madame vous avez la parole sur la sur
l'article 82ain
pr oui merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement que nous avions
déposé d'ailleurs en première lecture
revit une importance encore plus grande
aujourd'hui alors que la commission des
Lois du Sénat dans sa grande majorité
avait rejeté d'emblé le mode de scrutin
proposé par l'Assemblée nationale un
scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
l'Élysée a multiplié les pressions pour
revenir sur son refus de suivre les
députés et euh en l'absence des
sénateurs centristes d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a fait voter un amendement
rétablissant le texte de l'Assemblée
nationale or le choix de scrutin
majoritaire est vraiment mauvais pour
une démocratie seul le mode de scrutin
proportionnel oui permet de une juste
représentation de la population la
proportionnelle c'est certes une
garantie du renouvellement politique
mais aussi un rebed efficace contre la
notabilisation de nos institutions la
proportionnelle permet à la jeunesse
d'accéder aux fonctions électives elle
garantit et je souhaite quand même
particulièrement insister là-dessus le
respect de la règle constitutionnelle de
la parité la présence quasi majoritaire
de femmes au sein des conseils régionaux
en est d'ailleurs la démonstra
puisqu'elle représente environ 48 % les
perspectives dans le cas de l'option du
mode de scrutin prévu initialement qui
comprenait 20 % de proportionnel
abaissait déjà ce nombre de conseillères
territorial à 17,3 %. donc combien de
femmes seront élues conseillères
territorial en l'absence de ce comptat
de 20 % conformément à la volonté de
l'Assemblée nationale on pense 13 au
maximum ou 10 la plupart du temps
l'Institut tion du conseil territorial
qui trouve d'ailleurs sa raison d'être
dans l'objectif de reconquête des
collectivités territoriales si chè à
notre président représente donc avec le
mode de scrutin qui lui est donc
forcément joint une régression
importante sur le plan démocratique car
non seulement les territoires seront
moins bien représentés mais surtout les
femmes seront à nouveau écarté de la vie
politique faut-il le répéter seulle la
proportionnelle permet de bousculer les
vieilles et les mauvaises habitudes
et ce n'est pas un hasard d'ailleurs si
l'hémicycle ici au Sénat comprend plus
de femmes que celui de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est bien grâce au
département où l'élection se déroule à
la proportionnelle et il n'y a
d'ailleurs pas d'autrees raison et mon
collègue est là sans doute pour
m'appuyer bon la proportionnelle c'est
aussi la garantie du pluralisme le mode
de scrutin proportionnel permet une
juste représentation de l'ensemble des
courants d'idées il permet d'éviter la
dérive vers une politique spectacle ou
même par exemple élection présidentielle
ou la personnalisation masque les
propositions et les véritables enjeux
politiqu nous estimons donc qu'à
l'occasion de ce projet de loi il est
utile et grand temps d'affirmer la
nécessité d'un mode de scrutin
proportionnel pour revivifier notre
démocratie je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur votre avis sur le
82 bien monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre
le texte exact de cet amendement dit le
mode de représentation proposessionnelle
garantit le pluranisme et la parité dans
les assemblées élues il est évident que
cet amendement est dénué de toute portée
normative et que par la même ne peut pas
figurer dans ce projet de loi donc la
commission des lois a mis un avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre votre
avis avis défavorable monsieur mais avis
bien madame pour explication de vote
allez-y
madame oui monsieur le Président pour
rajouter quelques arguments à à ceux
déjà énoncés par ma collègue Josiane
matompoana et pour dire que peut-être
que cet amendement n'a pas de portée
normative mais nous avons connu déjà
d'autres amendements votés d'autres
articles de loi qui n'ont pas forcément
eux non plus de portter normative mais
lorsqu'il vous agré cela ils sont votés
donc donc voilà sur cet amendement
j'avais donc quelques arguments
supplémentaires et notamment une
question Quel est le prix du patriarcat
autrement dit combien coûte une
organisation sociale et juridique fondée
sur la détention de l'autorité politique
par les
hommes à cette question difficile le
gouvernement a réussi à apporter une
réponse très précise et mesurée en effet
si l'on suit l'amendement du
Gouvernement déposé à l'Assemblée le
mépris de la parité coûte exactement une
modulation partielle du tiers de la
moitié des subventions accordées en
fonction des résult aux élections
législatives et territoriales quel
affaire à ce prix-là c'est donné et si
pour certains l'évictions des femmes des
arènes territoriale est encore trop cher
la majorité ne reculant devant aucun
sacrifice cette modulation des
subventions sera calculée non pas en
fonction du nombre de femmes élues mais
en fonction du nombre de femmes
candidates encore mieux ce dispositif de
retenue financière pour les élections
des conseillers territoriaux est
totalement indolor puisqu'il ne crée pas
une alité financière supplémentaire mais
prend ce qui existe déjà en diminuant
d'un tiers l'assiette des retenues
applicables sur le financement des
élections législatives c'est moins cher
que gratuit dirait un bon
bonimenteur malheureusement nous ne
sommes pas ici sur la place du marché
mais au Parlement où nous devrions
normalement discuter de représentation
démocratique et de parité mais en guise
de proposition de loi comme l'avait
pourtant évoqué monsieur marlex nous
n'avons qu'un amendement voté en toute
urgence et sans concertation et qui
n'endiguera en rien l'hémorragie de
représentation des femmes créées par ce
mode de scrutin comme cela a été dit à
de multiples reprises à l'issue de cette
réforme il n'y aura au mieux que 17 % de
femmes conseillères territoriales contre
actuellement 47 % de conseillères
régional la parité ne s'instore pas à
coût d'incitation financières monsieur
le ministre surtout si ces incitations
financières sont dérisoires et indol
comme c'est le cas ici face à cette
régression de la parité sans précédent
parler de progrès significatif comme
vous l'avez fait monsieur le ministre
c'est un véritable
scandale
bien pour explication de vote vous avez
la parole mon cher collègue monsieur
Président je voulais dire quelques
peties chose que je dirais une fois que
je ne répéterai pas il y a deux modes de
scrutin qui existent et qui se partagent
les faveurs des uns ou des autres le
scrutin majoritaire et le scrutin de
représentation proportionnelle ces deux
scrutins sont des outils techniques qui
présentent chacun des avantages et des
inconvénients le scrutin majoritaire est
un scrutin plus efficace mais moins
juste la proportionnelle est un scrutin
plus juste mais moins efficace on
apprend ça à tous les étudiants de
premiè anné licence en droit je crois
que sur les problèmes de parité le
problème est un problème
fondamentalement différent je trouve
qu'il est humiliant particulièrement
humiliant pour les femmes que de
considérer que la seule façon
effectivement de de de permettre la
représentation politique des femmes
c'est de généraliser le scrutin
proportionnel comme s'il fallait
effectivement qu'il y ait des
contraintes comme s'il fallait qu'il y
ait j'allais dire un marteau et une
enclume comme s'il fallait qu'il y ait
effectivement systématiquement des lois
contraignantes pour que la parité puisse
se faire c'est une bien piètre
conception que du rôle des femmes je
crois qu'à partir du moment où des lois
tout à fait remarquables et qui ont été
voté d'ailleurs sous l'initiative de
d'un de nos collègues pierre Morrois
comme la loi sur les élections
municipales ont permis de faire en sorte
qu'il existe désormais dans les conseils
municipaux de toutes les communes de
plus de 3500 habitants aujourd'hui dans
toutes les communes de plus de 500
habitants demain un vivier d'élus local
capable de démontrer leurs compétences
capable de démontrer effectivement leur
notutoriété et le fait que ce soit des
excellentes candidates et bien je pense
que demain c'est lorsqu'il y aura la
parité avec le scrutin majoritaire que
nous pourrons chers collègues eu et
chers collègues tout court estimer avoir
fait réellement notre
travail
merci madame la Présidente borveau cenat
pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le SER chers
collègues nous avons eu le même la même
intervention la semaine dernière dans la
bouche de Madame trendley un homme une
femme un homme donc vous vous êtes
d'accord enfin en tout cas vous deux sur
les bandes de l'UMP pour nous expliquer
que c'était humiliant pour les femmes
d'être élu à la
proportionnelle je résume non je résume
mais force de constater mon cher
collègue que tant qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'obligation de parité qui ne peut
s'appliquer qu'avec le scrutin la
proportionnelle votre formation comme
d'autres d'ailleurs n'ont jamais fait la
parité vous avez inventé les pénalités
financières ça n'a rien donné du côté de
la parité dans votre formation politique
et dans la présentation que vous en avez
faite pire vous vous débrouillez en
général pour contourner la loi pour
garder quand même pour garder vos sièges
et ne pas faire la parité je pense à des
sénatoriales donc que chacun connaît
alors écoutez quand même il faudrait
éviter de nous faire la leçon de ce type
les femmes élues à la proportionnelle ne
sont pas humilié figurez-vous et elles
ont elles montrent qu'elles ont la
capacité effectivement d'être élu voilà
la preuve que vous pouvez trouver de la
loi sur la parité et de la
proportionnelle alors s'il vous plaît
vous n'allez pas à chaque fois nous
ressortir la même histoire parce que
vous avez essayé aussi les suppléentes
on vous a riononné pour les législatives
vous essayez de les réint ire avec les
conseillers territoriaux ben écoutez
nous rirons encore malheureusement jaune
peut-être parce que de fait vous faites
un recul historique de la parité qui est
à peine qui a à peine un tout petit peu
progressé depuis la loi sur la
parité bien euh monsieur min pour
explication de
vote merci monsieur le
Président la parole
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres nous ne voterons pas cet
amendement non pas pour apporter un
concours au gouvernement mais parce que
nous sommes convaincus au sein de notre
groupe que le scrutin uninominal est la
meilleure solution ceci étant ce qui
compte c'est le suffrage universel et il
n'est pas bon de considérer qu'un des
modes de scrutin serait au-dessous de
l'autre serait mauvais par rapport à la
démocratie
notre République a pendant longtemps
utilisé soit l'un soit l'autre selon les
régimes selon les changements de
majorité et nous nous considérons que le
scrutin majoritaire uninominal est celui
qui convient le mieux avec un
inconvénient que vous avez souligné
c'est le problème de la parité cela est
une
vérité si vous voulez ceci étant vous
savez je peux vous répondre que le
scrutin prop est souvent celui des
recalés du suffrage
universel
alors alors quand on voit quand on voit
ce que l'on peut voir dans certaines
élections je ne pense pas que le scrutin
proportionnel peut-être magnifié il a
ses avantages et ses inconvénients nous
nous considérons qu'il a plus
d'inconvénients que d'avantage c'est pas
pour ça que nous soutiendrons le
gouvernement bien chers collègues je
vous mets tous d'accord j'ai été saisi
d'une demande de scrutin public par le
groupe madame Blandin pardon j'avais pas
vu monsieur une telle
couverture j'avais pas vu madame blanda
derrière vous
couvert je pense que il y a des
arguments qu'il faut savoir renverser
par
l'absurde quand nous
entendons ce serait en quelque sorte
dévaloriser les femmes que de croire
qu'elles ont besoin du scrutin à la
proportionnelle pour accéder au
postes les premières vont vous répondre
si c'était le cas nous ne serions pas là
en particulier celles qui viennent de de
mode d'élection non à la proportionnelle
dans un nombre significatif de
départements mais il y a une autre
réponse à vous faire chers collègues
quand on regarde ces assemblées non
paritaires
si on cautionne votre raisonnement et
c'est votre raisonnement qui dirait cela
ça voudrait dire que toute proportion où
il y a moins de 50 % de femmes et la
preuve manifeste qu'elles ne sont pas
compétentes et moi je vous dis c'est pas
le cas c'est la preuve manifeste qu'il y
a des plafonds de verre des murs
invisibles des gros notables qui s'auto
reproduisent qui cumulent et qui gèlent
les poste alors je voterai cet
amendement bien bon mes chers collègues
alors nous allons passer au vote j'ai
été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe BMP sur
l'amendement 82 déposé par Madame
borveau et ses
collègues je vous rappelle que l'avis de
la commission est défavorable que le
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé à ce scrutin dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront au secrétaire un bulletin
blanc ceux qui souhaitent voter contre
vont remettre un bulletin bleu et ceux
qui souhaitent s'abtenir en mettrant un
bulletin rouge le scrutin va être ouvert
dans quelques
instants le scrutin est
ouvert
est clos j'invite Mesdames et Messieurs
les secrétaires à procéder au
dépouillement de ce
scrutin
voici mes chers collègues le résultat du
scrutin numéro 252 sur l'amendement 82
nombre de votants 339 suffrage exprimé
339 majorité absolue 170 pour l'adoption
140 contre
1819 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté toujours avant l'article premier
nous avons un amendement numéro 83 c'est
madame assassie qui le
défend Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président autre sujet récurrent que mon
groupe ESS de placer dans nos débats ici
dans l'hémicycle c'est celui du droit de
vote des
étrangers
alors je dois vous dire que nous sommes
lassés de répéter systém quement un
certain nombre
d'arguments je les ai d'ailleurs avancé
dernièrement en première lecture donc
pour défendre le droit de vote des
étrangers aux élections locales et puis
je ne vais pas les répéter donc je vais
en prendre de nouveaux arguments parce
que vous vous les
connaissez vu le nombre de fois
effectivement nous les avons
répété donc je vais me contenter entre
guillemets ici de réagir à un certain
nombre d'arguments qui ont été
développés en première lecture pour
s'opposer au vote de cet amendement sur
le droit de vote des étrangers aux
élections locales alors premier premier
le premier argument enfin la première
réponse à aux arguments euh c'est
peut-être la plus solide qui tient au
fait que le vote d'un tel amendement
nécessiterait une réforme
constitutionnelle alors c'est vrai c'est
c'est c'est c'est une réalité
mais elle est loin d'être indépassable
et à plusieurs reprises et sous diverses
formes nous avons proposé cette réforme
sans que la majorité ne daigne ni la
voter ni même s'y intéresser il nous
apparît donc quelque peu facile de se
draper dans le respect inconditionnel de
la Constitution alors même que le texte
que nous examinons tant dans le fond que
dans la forme est irrespectueux de la
Constitution à bien des égards il s'agit
à notre sens d'une manière de contourner
le débat et de ne pas se prononcer sur
le fond plus qu'une envie de respecter
scrupuleusement la norme
suprême un second argument qui a été
développé par monsieur le rapporteur est
que cet amendement relève du droit
électoral matière qui s'agissant de la
réforme territoriale relève du projet de
loi numéro numéro 61 relatif à
l'élection des conseillers territoriaux
argument et bien désormais invalide
puisque la Commission a intégré le mode
de scrutin au présent texte
un troisème argument développé dans cet
hémicycle émane cette fois-ci du Premier
ministre lui-même qui déclarait
récemment je le cite si nous sommes un
pays d'intégration ce n'est pas pour
offrir aux étrangers des demi-droits
électoraux mais pour les inviter à
acquérir s'il le souhaitent des droits
entiers en rejoignant pleinement notre
communauté nationale fin de citation
argument également invalide sur le fond
comme sur la forme d'abord sur le fond
parce que l'argument qui consiste à
conditionner l'accès au droit de à
l'acquisition de la nationalité
peut-être discuté dans le cadre
d'élection nationale où un lien évident
existe mais ici nous parlons d'élection
local qui n'engage pas le destin de la
nation dans son ensemble mais d'un
territoire il n'y a donc pas en l'espèce
de lien structurel entre nationalité
droit de vote et défendre le contraire
relève plus du dogmatisme que d'une
réelle réflexion institutionnelle sur la
forme parce que que comme le disait ici
même notre collègue de la majorité le
sénateur cointa je le cite on a trop
durci les conditions d'accès à la
nationalité française devenu aujourd'hui
un véritable une véritable course
d'obstacle fin de citation chers
collègues enfin un dernier argument
avancé dans cette émicycle consistait à
conditionner le droit de vote des
étrangers à une réciprocité de ce droit
dans les pays d'origine de ces personnes
cet argument est difficilement
compréhensible faut-il donner le droit
de vote aux seuls étrangers dont les
pays d'origine autorisent la réciprocité
et créer ainsi des différences de
traitement selon les origines
intolérables ou faut-il attendre que les
192 États membres des Nations Unis
deviennent tous de grandes démocratie
universaliste cet argument est à notre
sens un aveu de faiblesse si l'on
attendait la réciprocité à chaque fois
que nous légiférons nous n'aurions ni
CMU ni droit d'asile ni même aucun droit
pour les étrangers tout Simp simplement
le président de la République
probablement dans un moment de séduction
électoraliste je dirais pas un moment de
faiblesse c'est prononcé pour le droit
de vote des étrangers cette fois-ci nous
n'attendons pas de votre part d'è
arguments de façade vous permettant de
vous défaussé mais une position de
principe claire et intelligible la
majorité actuelle est-elle oui ou non
favorable au droit de vote des étrangers
aux élections locales euh c'est la
dernière fois que j'autoriserai un
dépassement il faut faire attention s'il
vous plaît non euh monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président
messieur les ministres c'est un
amendement qui a déjà été déposé en
première lecture et qui avait donc été
rejeté par le Sénat donc qui conduit
derrière la commission des lois à
confirmer son avis défavorable d'autant
que il s'agit là d'un sujet fondamental
qui demanderait des débats beaucoup plus
approfondis et qui ne serait être traité
par voie d'amendement dans cette loi
donc avis défavorable quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement avis défavorable monsieur
le Président je vous
remercie bien alors je vais il y a pas
de demande d'explication de vote je vais
mettre au madame borveau
exclusez-moi merci monsieur le Président
oui nous sommes désolés de vous
importuner avec le vote des étrangers
mais si vous voulez nous sommes quand
même dans une situation assez euh
ennuyeuse c'est que le vote des
étrangers est en discussion dans la
société en tout cas euh depuis très
longtemps et euh évidemment des
candidats à la présidentielle euh ont
fait des promesses plusieurs d'ailleurs
mais en tout cas le dernier en date en
considérant que oui euh effectivement
c'était une question qui euh pouvait se
non seulement se discuter mais peut-être
se faire or nous sommes en train de
discuter euh puisque vous le voulez
semble-t-il enfin on sait pas trop si
vous le voulez ou non mais en tout cas
c'est ce que nous faisons nous sommes en
train de discuter du mode de scrut pour
des élections qui viendront en
2014 ce qui fait que nous serons à plus
de 20 ans de discussion sur le droit de
vote des étrangers aux élections locales
étrangers qui vivent sur notre
territoire qui ont des titres de séjour
qui paient des impôts qui vont dont les
enfants vont à l'école et cetera et
cetera qui travaillent voilà donc euh
voyez ça commence à être un petit peu
inquiétant parce que on sait très bien
que cette question euh pose beaucoup de
problèmes en tout cas pour les personnes
concernées parce que justement comme
elle participe à la vie locale qu'elles
paient leurs impôts locaux et qu'elles
sont très intéressées à ce qui se passe
sur leur territoire souhaitent
participer aux élections en tout cas à
au niveau à ce niveau-là donc chaque
fois n on nous renvoie des débats futurs
alors on sait pas trop lesquels parce
qu'il y a eu les débats constitutionnels
pour la révision constitutionnelle au
opportunité évidemment de le faire nous
avons eu de multiples débats sur
différentes choses dans lequel nous
avons à chaque fois remis le sujet sur
le tapis à votre grand déplaisir certes
mais en tout cas puisque on avait quand
même l'idée que le Président de la
République actuelle peut-être allait
mettre en application une de ces
promesses alors que nous discutons de
beaucoup de choses dont il n'avait pas
parlé pendant la campagne électorale et
là évidemment chaque fois vous nous
renvoyez à des discussions futures à des
débats qui mériteraient beaucoup plus de
temps mais voyez depuis 20 ans on a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de temps pour parler
du vote des étrangers aux élections
locales et pendant ce temps et bien on
continue à rejeter ces populations d'une
façon ou d'une autre d'ailleurs parce
que on les rejette quelquefois de façon
beaucoup plus violente mais en tout cas
à ne pas faire ce geste qui aurait une
signification très forte pour les gens
de nation nationalité étrangère qui
vivent depuis longtemps souvent sur
notre territoire qui contribu à la vie
économique et cetera et cetera vous
connaissez tout ça alors on est en droit
de se demander mais quand voudrez-vous
en discuter est-ce que vraiment ça vous
fait peur est-ce que la République va
trembler sur ses bases parce que la
France comme d'autres pays je vous
signale que c'est le cas dans nombre de
pays européens que vous aimez à citer en
toutes circonstances en Irlande en Suède
au Danemark au Luxembourg au pays B donc
qu'est-ce quel est le problème
exactement en ce qui vous concerne donc
excusez-nous d'insister mais vraiment
nous insistonsès bien bien je vous
remercie donc je vais mettre au voie
l'amendement numéro 83 qui a un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement ceux qui sont pour lève la
main regardez
bien 1 2 3 4 5 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
25 26 27 28
2 il y en a une
qui ceux qui sont
contre
39 il n'est pas
adopté
maintenant nous avons SEP amendements
qui vont faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune c'est monsieur qui présente
c'est Monsieur
anzaniz le 304 s'il vous plaîoui
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues voilà un
amendement qui devrait tous nous
rassembler puisqu'il propose que chaque
assemblée territoriale soit administré
par des élus qui lui soi propre c'est un
amendement qui qui devrait nous réunir
effectivement puisque au fond il est
d'évidence il est d'évidence dans
l'histoire de notre République où
toujours une collectivité a été
administrée par un élu qui soit
spécifique il est évident sur le plan
constitutionnelle puisque notre
Constitution précise avec beaucoup de
clarté qu'aucune collectivité ne peut
exercer une tutelle sur une autre que
notre Constitution précise encore que
chaque collectivité territoriale doit
être autonome il est évident aussi
politiquement pour tous ceux et c'est un
argument que l'on retrouve souvent pour
tous ceux qui aspire à plus de
lisibilité et clarté mais alors si vous
voulez de la lisibilité et de la clarté
faites en sorte que l'électeur y
comprenne quelque chose et là vous
inventez un monstre à de têtes une tête
qui va penser pour le département une
tête qui va penser pour la région et
j'ajouterai que ce monstat de tête aura
même quatre pieds puisquil lui faudra
parcourir des cantons qui parfois
pourront avoir 70 km d'est en ouest ou
du nord au sud et il devra siéger à la
fois dans les organismes de la région et
dans les organismes des lycées donc ce
monstre à deux têtes et à qure pieds
évidemment personne ne le comprendra et
je voudrais appeler votre attcention sur
un moment précis qui est le moment de
l'élection que va-t-il se passer au
moment des élections du conseiller
territorial voilà quelqu'un qui devra
justif à la fois de son bilan et son
projet dans deux collectivités qui ne
seront pas peut-être de la même majorité
politique il devra donc s'expliquer sur
son bilan et son projet dans un
département qui aura telle majorité et
puis peut-être que il appartiendra lui
dans une à une région qui aura une autre
sensibilité et bien à l'évidence le
résultat sera la plus grande confusion
pour l'électeur alors est-ce que nous
souhaitons
l'obscurité de la vie
est-ce que nous souhaitons l'obscurité
pour nos collectivités territoriales si
nous le souhaitons pas il faut voter cet
amendement je vous remercie le
305 qui le
présente monsieur Boutan
oui monsieur le le président monsieur le
ministre nous proposons que so un
article additionnel disposant que les
conseillers de chaque assemblée
territoriale sont élus dans le cadre
d'une élection propre à chacune de ces
collectivités c'est en quelque sorte un
amendement additionnel à celui qui vient
d'être présenté par notre collègue
allziani les principes de respect de
l'autonomie des collectivités
territoriales et l'absence de tutelle
d'un niveau de collectivité sur un autre
inscrit dans la Constitution et dans la
loi impose que chaque collectivité
territoriale dispose d'élus qui lui soit
propre il convient non seulement que les
collectivités disposent d'élus qui leur
soit propre mais mais encore afin de
s'assurer d'une réelle organisation
décentralisée que les conseillers de
chaque assemblée soient élus dans le
cadre d'une élection spécifique une
élection commune à deux assemblées ne
permet pas de respect de le respect de
du principe d'interdiction des tutelles
de plus en confondant le conseiller
général et le conseiller régional en
conseiller territorial on dépouille les
conseillers
généraux ils sont passés à la moulinette
en quelque sorte alors que leur charge
de travail demeure la même en revanche
les conseils régionaux voit leurs
effectifs enflés au point de devenir des
assemblées plétoriques avec elle aussi
d'ailleurs la même charge de travail
qu'auparavant donc une injustice
vraiment criante
entre des effectifs d'un côté qui seront
plétoriques et des effectifs qui seront
de l'autre côté du côté des départements
j'informe le Sénat que les Pays-Bas
mèent 3 face àugu monsieur le
rapporteur non pardon c'est discussion
commune
306 le 306 qui le défend
monsieurur bien monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues cet
amendement donc souhaite voir chaque
collectivité territoriale administrée
par un Conseil donne dont l'élection
donne lieu à un scrutin spécifique
c'est-à-dire que cet amendement il est
en totale harmonie en totale cohérence
avec les deux amendements précédents
l'amendement 304 et 305 qui viennent de
vous être présentés c'est-à-dire que
l'objet reste identique reste le même à
savoir tout simplement le principe
constitutionnel relatif à l'autonomie
des collectivités territoriales qu'il
importe donc de respecter de la façon la
plus rigoureuse possible ce qui implique
en particulier l'absence de tutelle
d'une collectivité sur une autre tout
cela est inscrit dans la Constitution
tout cela est inscrit dans la loi et
bien évidemment cela nous impose de voir
chaque collectivité disposer d'élus qui
lui soit véritablement propre donc cet
amendement exige que chaque collectivité
soit administré par un conseil dont
l'élection donne lieu un scrutin
spécifique on voit très bien que là
encore notre souhait c'est d'aller vers
toujours plus loin en matière de de
clarification et cela dans tous les
domaines
or cette création de conseiller
territorial de par sa nature même de par
son essence et créateur de confusion et
cela dans tous les domaines en
particulier sur la question de ce mode
de scrutin un mode de scrutin qui anima
une grande partie de nos débats en
première lecture au Sénat une grande
partie des débats également à
l'Assemblée nationale ce qui montre que
et bien il ne s'impose à personne de
manière tout à fait naturelle et qu'il
est fortement contestable un conseiller
territorial je le répète qui n'était
attendu par personne qui n'était
revendiqué par personne et si l'on avait
au préalable en amont introduit
davantage de consultation de
concertation notamment avec les grandes
les grandes associations nationales
d'élus et bien je je crois que la
confusion dont il est question
aujourd'hui aurait été très largement
évitée on se souvient que la première
moutue prévoyé un scrutin mixte avec 80
% des conseillers territoriaux élus au
scrutin uninominal majoritaire à un tour
et les 20 % restant la proportionnelle
avec un effet perverse inacceptable à
savoir l'existence possible d'élus par
défaut d'élus hors sol en quelque sorte
puisque les simulations faisaient une
démonstration éclatante que l'on pouvait
arriver à avoir des élus mais également
des présidents d'association ne pouvant
s'appuyer sur aucune légitimité
démocratique en particulier sur celle du
bulletin de vote un peu plus tard nous
avons assisté à un épisode suivant à
savoir que le 5 mai le bureau politique
de l'UMP tranché en faveur d'un scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours secs
c'est-à-dire excluant excluant les
triangulaires et là je dirais que la
ficelle nous a semblé quand même un
petit peu grosse dans la mesure où
l'objectif suivant semble-t-il et bien
c'était une extension probable de ce
mode de scrutin au scrutin
législatif là encore donc les visés
électoraliste l'emporté et écartter la
dose proportionnelle pourtant adopté en
première lecture au Sénat donc une
nouvelle fois et bien un principe
démocratique un principe de
représentativité la plus équitable
possible était en quelque sorte dominé
par une donnée électoraliste et
partisane éclatante la commission des
Lois du Sénat en seconde lecture a
rejeté le mode d'élection du Conseil
Territorial au scrutin uninominal
majoritaire à deux tours c'est bien
évidemment la raison qui a emporté on ne
peut transposer au niveau local un mode
de scrutin qui s'applique au niveau
national le seil de 12,5 % pour passer
au second tour ne permet pas de
respecter la diversité des choix des
électeurs nous entendons donc que soit
prise en compte la particularité de
l'organisation territoriale
décentralisée de la
République le 308 K pour le groupe
socialiste madame
Landin la région c'est vraiment un
fleuron de la décentralisation que
l'intelligence visionnaire de grand
homme a fait émerger et de grands hommes
elle nous hissse oui puisqu'il y a
Gaston de fer et Pierre Morrois elle
nous hissent à la hauteur des
territoires européen elle donne sens à
la vraie décentralisation celle qui se
construit sur la démocratie et la région
a fait vivre la démocratie
contractualisant avec l'État ses choix
avec les contrats de plan assurant les
liens avec les départements les communes
les pays avec des cofinancements et une
juste répartition des rôles garantissant
la diversité politique et la parité dans
ces assemblées les régions ont montré ce
qu'elles savaient faire grâce à des élus
disponibles le désamiantage des lycées
que l'État avait transféré
contaminé la gestion du TER alors que la
SNCF ne savait même pas donner des
comptes où se distinguerit le coût de
l'exploitation dans chaque région du
coût du matériel ou les dépenses du
siège central cette prise de
responsabilité du TER a permis enfin de
régler les fréquences sur les besoins
des usagers de réhabiliter les gardes
d'augmenter la fréquentation de
commander du matériel et de
des milliers d'emplois la coopération
Nord-Sud avec des partenariats de
société à société et pas simplement des
jumelages d'élus voilà de l'autonomie
économe efficace bien comprise et vous
voudriez remplacer ces
conseillers par des conseillers cons
substantiellement modifié bivalent et
cumular éloignant de fait les
conseillers régionaux des missions où
ils excellent pour qu'ils aillent se
mêler de missions sociales ù Excell
d'autres conseillers départementaux cela
notre amendement est donc
solennel il prêche cette autonomie et la
sauvegarde des conseillers régionaux en
l'état et je vous invite à les soutenir
merci qui défend le 18
rectifié monsieur
Douin merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'intervention sera courte
donc je vais rattraper le temps dépassé
par mon collègue précédent cet
amendement se situe dans la ligne droite
interventions précédentes il se propose
il propose d'insérer un article
additionnel affirmant que l'autonomie
des départements doit être garantie par
l'élection de conseillers qui leur sont
spécifique cet amendement trouve sa
motivation profonde dans le principe
constitutionnel d'interdiction de
l'exercice d'une tutelle par une
collectivité sur une autre et nous
mesurons combien la création de cet élu
qui a été maintenant régulièrement
qualifié d'hybride ou à deux têtes
commun à plusieurs collectivités
violerit automatiquement cette
disposition constitutionnel c'est
pourquoi je vous invite à voter et
adopter cet amendement merci merci
Monsieur don le 319 rectifié monsieur
Teston vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président cette amendement
propose d'insérer un article additionnel
visant à préciser que l'absence de
tutelle de la région sur le département
est garanti par l'élection de
conseillers qui sont spécifiques à
chacune de ces collectivités cet
amendement met donc en œuvre le principe
de non tutelle qui est posé par la
première phrase de l'alinéa 5 de
l'article 72 de la Constitution je le
cite aucune collectivité territoriale ne
peut exercer une tutelle sur une autre
fin de citation or la création du
conseiller territorial ne permet pas de
respecter cette disposition
constitutionnelle en effet créer un élu
siégeant à la fois au conseil général et
au conseil régional fait automatiquement
prendre le risque que cet élu conseiller
général à certains moment et conseiller
régional à d'autres confonde ses
responsabilités et fasse primer un jour
ou l'autre les intérêts d'une
collectivité sur l'autre le seul moyen
en notre sens d'éviter ce risque est de
renoncer à la création du conseiller
territorial la commission des lois a
déjà supprimé l'article 1er a nous
sommes donc en bonne voie il faut
poursuivre dans cette voie je vous
invite donc à adopter sans sourciller
cet amendement je vous
remercie et maintenant le 320
rectifié Monsieur domzel Merci monsieur
le Président même messieurs messieurs
les
ministres à partir du moment où le
conseiller territorial ou la conseillère
territoriale siégerait à la fois au
conseil régional et au conseil général
entraînera de fait une tutelle du
département sur la région cet amendement
propose de prévoir expressément que
l'absence de tutelle du département sur
la région est garantie par l'élection
des de conseillers qui sont spécifi à
chacune de ces collectivités en
application de l'article 72 de la
Constitution cet amendement il est vrai
et le pendant du précédent en effet on
ne serait pas plus acceptter une tutelle
du département sur la région qu'une
tutelle de la région sur le département
or la création du conseiller territorial
fait encourir un sévère risque
d'inconstitutionnalité et là on ne peut
pas se permettre de prendre le risque
que les compétences de la région et du
département s'ans chevêtre c'est
exactement ce que fait courir la
création de ce fameux conseiller
territorial c'est pourquoi je vous
invite à adopter cet amendement merci
Monsieur laiselle bon maintenant je vais
entendre le rapporteur
le président de la commission des lois
souhait s'exprimer il a la parole oui
monsieur le Président il faudra quand
même pour l'organisation d'au débats
qu'on respecte au moins le règlement
l'article 1er qui crée le conseiller
territorial a été voté en termes
identiques par les deux assemblées aucun
des amendement n'est compatible avec le
vote intervenu donc normalement il
devrait il devrait tomber
alors non non mais je le dis non
gentiment parce que non mais c'est vrai
vous le savez bien et donc parce
qu'autrement il y a une contradiction
totale vous mais
non non monsieur le l'irrecevabilité
c'était la demande du gouvernement et je
n'ai pas été vigilant effectivement ça
aurait pu être demandé au niveau de la
commission mais je vous supplie quand
même qu'on respecte un petit peu le
règlement dans cette assemblée parce
qu'à ce momentlà les débats deviennent
complètement confus
et et et vous voulez que je vous donne
un exemple quand même de de de ce que
vous arrivez à écrire je crois pas qu'il
a été défendu le 307
rectifié non il est pas en discussion
commune non il est pas en discussion
commune et ben j'attends celle-là alors
écoutez moi monsieur le Président on
peut voter effectivement mais s encore
des explications de vote nombreus sur ce
sujet moi je demanderai l'irrecevabilité
je vous préviens déforable donc vous
êtes défavorable à l'ensemble des
amendements et le
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre je pense que vous suivez la
position de la Commission oui tout à
fait mais je bon on parlait de la forme
mais on peut aussi parler du fond hein
je dire au point où on en est prenons
quelques instants pour pour en parler
hein il est déjà 10h20 ça va alors moi
quatre observations très rapidement
bon pour argumenter contre bien sûr
premièrement le principe d'élu siégeant
dans les assemblées départementales et
régionales a été adopté comme l'a
rappelé le président en première lecture
par le Sénat et par l'Assemblée
nationale il n'y a pas donc lieu de
revenir trop sur ce point qui a fait
l'objet d'un accord c'est voter deème
observation aucune règle aucune règle
constitutionnelle n'impose un tel
principe si l'article 72 de la
Constitution dispose d'une part et je
cite que les collectivités s'administre
librement par des conseills élus et
d'autre part que aucune collectivité
territoriale ne peut exercer une tutelle
sur une autre la jurisprudence du du
Conseil constitutionnel n'a jamais
interdit que des mêmes élus puissent
siéger dans des collectivités
différentes d'ailleurs il existent déjà
des assemblées territoriales cons
constitué d'élus qui siègent dans
d'autres assemblées c'est par exemple
l'exemple connu de de la Nouvelle
Calédonie qui est un territoire français
troisièmement mais troisièmement le
comité
baladure a d'ailleurs longuement examiné
cette question et a estimé je je cite
entre guillemets ça a été d'ailleurs
adopté à l'unanimité des membres du du
de la commission Baladur qu'il résultait
de la jurisprudence constitutionnelle
qu'il ne serait pas contraire à la
Constitution qu'une seule opération
électorale serve à désigner les
conseillers départementaux et les
conseillers régionaux autrement dit il
n'y a aucune difficulté sur le plan
constitutionnel et enfin au niveau du
Conseil d'État puisque allons chercher
des grandes références c'est ce qu'a
d'ailleurs très très clairement
réaffirmé le Conseil d'État quand il a
examiné les projets de loi liés à la
réforme en estimant et je le cite que
n'était contraire à aucun principe la
désignation par un unique scrutin de
conseillers territoriaux destinés à
siéger tant au Conseil Général qu'au
Conseil
régional bien je vais mettre au voix le
ceux qui sont pour lève la
main
comptez avis
contraire il n'est pas
adopté monsieur monsieur Colomba pour
explication alors je mets 305 même vote
vous êtes d'accord pas d'objection je
vous remercie le 306 monsieur galambin
pour explication de vote alors je
voudrais intervenir à propos des des des
amendements 306 et 308 mes collègues ont
ont insisté et la réponse une partie de
réponse leur a été donnée sur le fait
qu'on risquait euh de contrevenir par le
système qui nous est proposé ou qui nous
sera proposé à l'article 72 de la
Constitution je pense qu'une partie des
réponses qui ont été données sont
satisfaisantes sauf que sauf que que se
passe-t-il
dans les régions constituées de deux
départements démographiquement très
hétérogènes dans la mesure où à la
différence d'aujourd'hui ce seront bien
ce sera bien le le Conseil ça sera bien
le Conseil Général du Nord qui sera dans
le conseil régional du N pas de calis
puisque d'ailleurs comme disait monsieur
Fab esprit et encore une fois j'aime le
citer l'assemblée régionale est formée
fondamentalement de la réunion de
conseils généraux dans ce cas-là dans le
il y a le donc la Haute Normandie euh
l'Alsace très
franchement il y a quand même un petit
problème qui se pose oh vous le réglerez
bien avec le Conseil constitutionnel il
sait s'adapter ça je n'en doute pas
enfin là il y a quand même un petit
problème mais ce sur quoi je voudrais
attirer l'attention c'est autre chose
tout à l'heure notre collègue Jean-René
leerf fait d'habitude je suis plutôt
d'accord avec ce qu'il dit nous a dit
bah écoutez chaque mode de scrutin ses
avantages et ses inconvénients il nous a
rappelé voilors le scrutin majoritaire
c'est l'efficacité le scrutin
proportionnel c'est plus de justice et
cetera par efficacité je suppose que
comme le nom l'indique ou semble
l'indiquer scrutin majoritaire ça crée
des majorités bon tout le problème c'est
quand l'espèce ça crée pas forcément des
majorités et moi je me suis amusé enfin
les amateurs de de littérature un peu
curieuse ont peut-être lu quelques
parties du rapport que j'ai commis sur
sur
cette sur cette affaire bien et bien de
quoi s'aperçoiton on s'aperçoit que
quand on examine à peu près les scrutins
possibles pour le conseiller territorial
que le tous les modes de scrutin
envisagés il il apparaît que plus un
mode de scrutin majoritaire assure de
majorité stable au niveau départemental
plus il les rend aléatoire au niveau
régional c'est ça le fond du débat
c'estàdire que le risque j'aurais
l'occasion d' j'aurais l'occasion d' d'y
revenir le risque avec un mode de
scrutin tel qu'il va nous être proposé
c'est que on n'est plus au niveau
régional comme actuellement l'assurance
d'une majorité parce que mon cher
collègue et on l'a même vu on l'a même
vu dans le mode dans le les résultats
des dernières élections
britanniques même avec un scrutin
aussi rigide que le scrutin un nominale
à un tour il y a pas eu de majorité et
qu'est-ce qu'on constate et bien on
constate si vous regardez les les
résultats en détail certes le Parti
libéral a eu moins de scrutin de moins
de de sièges que normalement le nombre
de voix qu'il a obtenu pouvait le
permettre mais si vous prenez les tout
petits
partis les partis plus ou moins
nationaliste
écossais irlandais catholique protestant
tout ce que vous voulez il y en a une
pas par d'elle comme on dit chez nous et
bien vous constatez que les résultats en
siège qu'ils ont sont équivalents au
résultats en voie dans un mode de
scrutin et c'est ce sur quoi je vaux
attirer votre attention majoritaire
uninominale les formations voir les
individualités qui disposent de bastions
locaux peuvent être représentés peuvent
être élu et dans des situations où vous
aurez un équilibre entre ce que
j'appellerai la la gauche de
gouvernement et la droite de
gouvernement quoi les coalitions qui
gouvernent actuellement les les les
régions et bien vous pourrez avoir et je
fais le Paris que dans un certain nombre
de départ de de régions vous aurez des
majorités qui seront à la qui seront à
la merci de ces coalitions de briqu et
de broc avec des
formations ultra minoritaires voire avec
des personnalités qui s'assureront un
avenir par ce biais-là voilà c'est ce
sur quoi je voulais attirer votre
attention
si en couplant mais c'est mathématique
vous pourvez dire tout ce que vous
voulez et j'en prends le Paris j'en
prends le Paris j'en prends le Paris
hein si vous assurez un scrutin si
vousrutez si vous assurez pardon une
majorité sû au niveau départemental par
exemple avec une prime majoritaire vous
fragilisez le niveau régional c'est ça
vous ne pouvez pas avoir en même temps
une majorité régionale assurée et une
majorité départementale assurée ce
scrutin dit majoritaire n'est pas
toujours majoritaire merci Monsieur
colomin monsieur maçon pour explication
de vote plus Monsieur Jean René leerf
après je voudrais je voudrais dire mon
indignation à l'égard des propos qui ont
été tenus car vouloir dire que parce que
il y a des petits partis ou des
candidats indépendants il ne représente
rien que c'est je dis je reprends les
termes des élus de BRI et de
broc parce que moi j'en conclus que je
suis un sénateur de brique et de broc
non c'est quand même bon je sais je sais
bon mais je crois quand même qu'il y a
une démocratie je crois qu'il y a une
démocratie et quand on fait des voix et
qu'on présente des suffrages et bien on
n'est pas des sénateurs ou des élus de
BRI et
au niveau des noninscrits nous sommes se
nous avons chacun fait nos voix nous
avons chacun été élu et c'est quand même
un peu scandaleux que quelqu'un vienne
nous dire dans cette enceinte que les
gens qui se font élire parce que ils
sont pas dans un parti et cetera c'est
des élus de brique et de broc et bien
moi je le dis je ne suis pas un élu de
brique et de broc je donne rendez-vous
je donne rendez-vous au prochain
renouvellement sénatorial aussi bien à
la droite qui à la gauche et on contrat
les B et ceci étant j'en reviens à
modification de vote je vrais dire que
c'est ce projet de loi à mon avis est
globalement
entaché d'un certain nombre de final
d'arrièrepensée politique et je suis
globalement contre par contre le fait
d'avoir un mode de scrutin unique pour
les conseillers généraux et les
conseillers régionaux c'est une
excellente chose car actuellement au
niveau des conseils généraux et des
conseils régionaux on assiste à bagarre
permanente des conflits permanents les
uns savent pas ce qui se passe dans les
dans les dans les autres assemblées je
peux vous dire j'ai été pendant 3 ans à
la fois conseil général et conseil
régional et bien ça a été une ouverture
finalement parce que on voit la
globalité des problèmes aussi bien les
problèmes des conseils généraux que des
problèmes des conseils régionaux et je
pense très honnêtement que c'est une
bonne chose bien merci chers collèg je
voudrais informer le
que les Pays-Bas ont battu l'Uruguay TR
buts à
de ah ben je n'ai pas de prise sur les
événements monsieur le
C monsieur le Président je voudrais
répondre d'un mot à mon collègue Colomba
pour lui rappeler que les règles en
termees de mode de scrutin sont des
règles tendantielles et qu'il arrive
effectivement à un scrutin majoritaire
d'être parfois profondément injuste
puisque parfois il permet à une minorité
de devenir majoritaire en siège c'est
surtout le cas du scrutin majoritaire à
un tour ça c'est déjà vu effectivement
en Grande-Bretagne et ça s'est déjà vu
également d'une autre manière pour
l'élection présidentielle américaine
mais il arrive de la même manière et
relativement plus souvent que la
proportionnelle soit particulièrement
injuste puisque si on prend le cas de la
4e République par exemple on peut
estimer effectivement que en raison de
la proportionnelle nous n'avions que des
gouvernements de coalition qui ne
faisaient nullement la politique de
quelque parti que ce soit et donc plus
personne ne se trouvait représenté et
puisque j'ai la parole je la garde un
instant pour
une double remarque une première
remarque pour dire fort amicalement à
mon collègue Anziani que des monstres à
deux têtes et à quatre pattes moi j'en
connais beaucoup moi qui suis élu
effectivement d'un département d'une
région qui sont plutôt à gauche je
connais des collègues socialistes qui
sont à la fois effectivement conseillers
généraux conseillers régionaux parfois
qui sont même dans les exécutifs et qui
sont donc de ces monstres que je leur
ferai remarquer effectivement que je
navais pas constaté cette apparence
jusqu'à présent d'autre part ce problème
de la tutelle moi je je connais bien les
problèmes de tutelle il y a fort
longtemps mes chers collègues nous
pouvions peut-être parler d'une tutelle
du mari sur l'épouse parler du d'une
tutelle peut-être du propriétaire sur le
locataire ou du patron sur l'ouvrier
mais je n'ai entendu personne parmi vous
dire qui exerçait la tutelle est-ce que
c'est la région qui exerce la tutelle
sur le département ou le département qui
exerce la tutelle sur la région voilà
une question à laquelle vous êtes tous
incapable de de répondre et je crois que
cela permet de ruiner l'argumentation
qui est la vôtre
d'inconstitutionnalité en raison de
l'exercice d'une tutelle de l'un sur
l'autre encore faudrait-il savoir de qui
il s'agit merci Monsieur Teston
oui merci monsieur le Président je
souhaite expliquer mon vote sur
l'ensemble des amendements par lesquels
nous faisons en sorte d'essayer
d'obtenir qu'on reconnaisse clairement
dans le projet de loi l'absence de
tutelle d'une collectivité sur une autre
alors j'ai entendu monsieur marlex
évoquer tout à l'heure la décision du
Conseil
constitutionnel relative à la Nouvelle
Calédonie et il a indiqué qu'elle lui
paraissait transposable au cas d'espèce
c'est-à-dire au projet de création du
conseiller
territorial or il est vrai que en 1985
le Conseil
constitutionnel estimant que ce
territoire était représenté par une
seule assemblée a conclu que rien
nempêcha aux élus une double fonction à
la fois territoriale et régionale mais
nous ne sommes pas dans ce cas de figure
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un cas où
s'il y a pour
l'avenir un projet de quasif fusion
entre le département et les régions les
deux échelons pour l'instant subsistent
et il y a bien donc deux personnes
morales distincte avec des budgets et
des compétences distinctes donc
l'argumentation développée par Monsieur
MX ne tient absolument pas ce n'est pas
un bon argument pour s'opposer à ce que
nous demandons et nous y voyons une fois
de plus la volonté de faire en sorte de
créer un conseiller territorial dont on
ne sait même pas si la création est
constitutionnelle j'ai tendance à consid
qu'elle ne l'
pas je vous remercie alors je vais
mettre au voie l'amendement
306 la Commission et le gouvernement
sont compte qui est
pour s'il vous plaît maintenez vos bras
levés pour que j'ai le temps de
compter 35 36 37
vé 44 6
48 qui est
contre alors 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 27
28 29 30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38 39
c'est bon l'amendement n'est pas
adopté mais chers collègues je pense que
sur le les suivants vous êtes expliqué
on peut considérer même vote
monsieur Colomba une oui mais relance
peut-être pas tout le débat je relance
pas le débat simplement je voulais dire
à à Jean-René leerf qu' au moins pour le
Pas de Calais je sais qui a sur la
tutelle sur qui c'est le nord du Nord
pas decalais c'est le département du
Nord sur la région nordp decalais et
indirectement sur sur le sur le pas de
calais et s'agissant de l'intervention
de notre collègue maçon voulais
simplement dire je voulais simplement
dire que je n'ai pas parlé d'élu de
brick et de broc j'ai parlé de majorité
de BRI et de broc et si simplement
simplement je vois ce qui se ce qui se
passe si la majorité dans la région
Lorine dépend de sa voix je leur
souhaite bien du
plaisir bien mais les absents ont
toujours t ça ça gagne du temps alors je
mets le 308 même vote il y a pas
d'objection je peux considérer que les
autres amendements même vote pas
d'objection je vous remercie de votre
compréhension euh je maintenant le 307
rectifié monsieur Mirassou monsieur
Mirassou vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président n avons rendez-vous faites
bien alors figurez-vous que cet
amendement décline de l'amendement 306
et il vise à affirmer contre V et Maré
que chaque collectivité à notre sens
doit disposer d'un mode de scrutin qui
lui soit propre si je vous dis ça
monsieur yes c'est parce que je sais ce
que vous allez me répondre et vous allez
me répondre que dès l'instant où
l'article 1 est considéré comme acquis
c'est bon très bien alors je répondrai
d'une autre manière parce que le mode de
scrutin encore toujours à notre sens
doit être adapté à la réalité
territoriale et cela a été dit par
ailleurs on ne peut transposer au niveau
décentralisé le mode de scrutin qui
s'applique au niveau national pas plus
du reste qu'on doit imposer un scrutin
en en fonction de tentation qui pourrait
être
électoraliste le scrutin doit répondre à
une situation de fait objectivable en
l'occurrence l'organisation
décentralisée de la République et il est
évident dès lors que c'est la réalité
territoriale qui doit inspirer le mode
de scrutin et non un mode de scrutin qui
aurait pour but de redessiner en quelque
sorte arbitrairement des résultats
électoraux précédents qui dérangent
j'ajoute que le seuil de 12 8 % ne
permet pas de respecter la diversité des
choix des électeurs et par la même ne
permet pas non plus l'implantation d'une
véritable démocratie locale je vous
remercie c'est monsieur le Président qui
répond monsieur le rapporteur délègue
bien alors je ne sais pas si la fatigue
des fabricants d'amendements étaiit là
je ne sais pas si vous vous avez lu ce
que vous avez écrit chaque collectivité
dispose pas chaque catégorie chaque
collectivité dispose d'un scrutin qui
lui est propre donc les 36000 communes
pe avoir chacune leur scrutin les
conseil c'est c'est franchement je crois
qu'il vaut mieux leur tirer assez vite
non non il faut mieux le retirer assez
vite parce qu'autrement vous sombrez
dans le ridicule
excusez-moi quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement il est évidemment
défavorable pour les raisons que vient
indter le président de la commission
monsieur Mirou vous le
maintenez monsieur se la parole sera
plus facile pour tout le
monde si si marche très
bien à qui la
faute la faute à ceux qui
réservant cette série
je sais
pas monsieur mirasso a dû casser son
micro mais par il est casser le micro
oui casser la voix voilà non je disais
que on peut pas éluder le fait que cet
amendement est peut-être décalé par
rapport à l'article 1er mais en même
temps s'il est décalé c'est parce que
ceux qui ont pris l'initiative de
réserver une série de article et
d'amendement nous ont géographiquement
et temporairement éloigné du cheminement
normal de l'étude de ce dossier donc à
chacun sa responsabilité et en ce qui me
concerne même si je suis prêt à Semander
je ne retire
rien bon alors je vais le mettre au voix
ceux qui sont pour lève la
main avis
contraire
il n'est pas
adopté maintenant nous allons appeler le
310 qui le défend c'est toujours
monsieur Mirassou non c'est moi monsieur
Colomba excusez-moi oui alors ne touchez
pas le micro il tient le coup encore je
non simplement j'ai j'ai bien conscience
que cette cet amendement aurait plus sa
place dans le le projet 61 qui concerne
les les modes les modes de scrutin mais
comme aujourd'hui tout est dans tout et
réciproquement ma foi et que pour que
les choses arrivent à monter jusque au
sommet il faut commencer il faut il faut
enfoncer le clou non il s'agirait
simplement d' d'un amendement que nous
que nous reprendrons parce que je pense
pas qu'il prospérera ce soir qui
consiste à demander à ce que le mode de
scrutin pour la désignation des des des
délégués des des délégués pardon
communaux aux intercommunalités des
communes de de moins de 500 habitants
soi élus selon le même mode de scrutin
que les autres c'est-à-dire l'extension
donc qui est prévu du mode de scrutin
actuellement pour les communes de plus
de 3500 habitants dans la mesure où nous
considérons qu'il y a pas à traiter de
manière différente ces petites communes
qui sont des communes à part entière
comme toutes et puis ce qui permettrait
aussi une meilleure extension du
principe de parité voilà monsieur le
Président ce que je voulais dire
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur Colomba
fait la présentation plus en même temps
l'explication de la commission donc je
lui confirme que son avis défavorable
bien quel est l'avis du Gouvernement
défavorable parce que le gouvernement
monsieur le Président a retenu le seuil
à 500 suivant recommandation de la MF je
vous remercie il est maintenu je le mets
au voie ceux qui sont pour lève la
main est-ce qu'il y a des avis
contraires il n'est pas
adopté le
311 madame Bonnefoi madame
Bonnefoi merci monsieur le Président la
révision constitutionnelle du 8 juillet
1999 a ajouté à l'article 3 de la
Constitution de 1958 devenu depuis
l'article 1er la disposition selon
laquelle la loi favorise l'égal accès
des femmes et des hommes au mandats
électoraux et aux fonctions électives le
projet du gouvernement constitue une
régression manifeste et inacceptable de
la parité qui a pourtant été consacré
dans la Constitution ce recul de la
parité s'avère donc inacceptable pour la
démocratie elle-même depuis la loi du 31
janvier 2007 la parité est devenue une
exigence pour les exécutifs régionaux
aujourd'hui le caractère bénéfique de
cette représentation ne peut en aucun
cas être remis en cause à forciorie il
est indispensable au bon fonctionnement
de nos institutions ce principe ne
saurait être contesté un retour en
arrière est impensable dans ce domaine
l'amendement que je vous propose en
précisant la composition des conseils
régionaux respecte les principes de la
parité il permet d'inscrire dans la loi
que le Conseil régional doit être
composé d'un nombre égal d'hommes et de
femmes cet amendement vise donc à
conforter la parité dans les conseils
régionaux je vouserci quel est l'avis du
rapporteur mais c'est un amendement
principe qui dénué toute portée
normative donc un avis défavorable avis
du gouvernement avis défavorable on aura
l'occasion d' revenir ailleurs bien met
au voix ceux qui sont pour veulent bien
lever la
main est-ce qu'il y a des avis
contraires il n'est pas
adopté au chapitre 1er avant l'article
1er AA nous avons un amendement numéro
84 qui va nous être présenté par
Monsieur verra
oui merci monsieur le Président messieur
les ministres mes chers
collègues chapitre 1er du projet de loi
crée le très controversé conseiller
territorial qui doit se substituer dans
un dédoublement étrange au conseiller
régional et au conseiller général
dédoublement étrange puisque les deux
assemblées à la région et au département
continueront d'exister au moins pour un
temps et le conseiller territorial devra
effectuer ce double travail
politique alors que l'exigence est au
rapprochement des élus de le lieu
d'élection au au plus près des citoyens
la création du conseiller territorial va
accroître la distance entre les élus et
la
population cette coupure proviendra
également de la professionnalisation
inéluctable de la fonction tant la
charge sera lourde la création du
conseiller
territorial
institutionnalise le cumulle des mandats
puisque il s'agira d'exercer deux
fonctions de depuis la première lecture
le doute s'est encore renforcé au sein
même de la majorité sur la création du
conseiller territorial car une réelle
confusion apparaît quant à
l'architecture territoriale
future quel sera le rôle du conseiller
territorial accompagner la mort du
département ou de la région ou bien la
création des métropoles le conseiller
territorial de fait ne se
transformera-t-il pas en un simple
gestionnaire ce qui apparaît d'ailleurs
logique puisque l'aire du temps est à la
suppression de la libre administration
des
communes alors monsieur le président de
la commission des lois vous estimer que
le conseiller territorial ne devrait
plus être remis en cause du fait de la
conformité de l'article 1er et pourtant
l'examen en commission a montré la
fragilité de l'existence de cette
nouvelle fonction élective et le
conseiller territorial qui est une
hérésie démocratique peut-être encore
supprimé il vous suffit mes chers
collègues de voter contre ce projet de
loi en attendant le vote final une
solution existe peut-être moins
douloureuse pour certains membres de la
majorité et bien il s'agit de supprimer
le chapitre premier nous vous proposons
donc de voter notre amendement pour
concrétiser clairement le refus de la
création du conseiller
territorial une exigence qui prend force
et qui monte dans la société et parmi
les
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cet amendement vise à supprimer
des dispositions relatives à la création
des consiliers territoriaux or cela est
impossible puisque l'article prer qui
opère cette création a été adopté
conforme par l'Assemblée nationale et n
donc plus en discussion cet amendement
est théoriquement irrecevable il est
alors faut le dire il
est bon alors la commission dit qu'il é
ev puisqueil a déjà été voté bon donc il
tombe avant l'article 1er AA nous avons
un amendement 479 rectifié le président
Collin président
Collin non monsieur le maître
mard monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres cet amendement dont la
présentation d'ailleurs rappelle un peu
la diversité de notre groupe
euh a pour objet de
fixer les principes généraux de
délimitation de la future carte
cantonale ou territorial plutôt il
s'agit dans notre esprit de prendre acte
du processus de rationalisation et
d'achèvement de la carte de
l'intercommunalité achèvement de la
carte de l'intercommunalité que nous n
souhaitons d'aller au bout de cette
logique et de faire ainsi des
intercommunalités la brique de base de
la future carte
territoriale il nous paraît là ce n'est
que brick et pas Brock bon il nous
paraît essentiel que la répartition des
sièges de conseillers territorial
correspondent aux logique mise en œuvre
pour définir la carte des
intercommunalités bassin de vie
cohérence territoriale et géographique
homogénéité économique et sociale prise
en compte de la div des espaces et des
problématiques dans un même département
notre amendement propose donc comme
principe de base qu'une même
intercommunalité soit nécessairement
comprise dans le territoire d'un même
canton d'un même territoire étant bien
sûr entendu que les intercommunalité qui
débordent le cadre d'un seul département
ne peuvent être comprises dans le même
canton le critère
démographique constituerit le premier
critère du découpage afin de ménager un
réel équilibre du poids démographique de
chaque canton au sein d'un même
département et de ne pas laisser
subsister comme aujourd'hui des
déséquilibres qui porte atteinte à
l'égalité du
suffrage en revanche seuls les
intercommunalités les plus peuplées
auraient vocation à être découpé en
plusieurs territoires en fonction d'un
critère de population aligné sur la
moyenne théorique d'habitants d'un
canton du département nous refusons que
les petites intercommunalités fassent
l'objet de découpage qui affaiblirit
l'homogénéité et la cohérence des
bassins de vie qu'elles incarnent enfin
ce découpage serait aligné en toute
logique sur celui de l'achèvement et de
la rationalisation de
l'intercommunalité dont nous vous
proposerons par d'autres amendements
d'avancer la date du 1er juillet au 1er
mars
2013 je vous remercie votre avis
monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre cet amendement est
naturellement contraire à la position de
la Commission qui a souhaité en insérant
article 1 AA nouveau créer une nouvelle
circonscription pour l'élection des
conseillers territoriaux et
naturellement conserver les cantons
existant dans leur forme actuelle comme
étant une circonscription administrative
de plus il ne nous paraît pas opportun
de tenir compte des limites des EPCI
parce que les EPC sont par définition
des variables dans le dans leur
territoire géographique il peut y avoir
des fusions de PCI des agrandissements
de territoire donc on veut pas les figer
à ce niveau-là et puis deuxièmement le
découpage il est prévu dans le premier
dans l'article 1er aA les bases du
découpage respecteront la diversité
géographique économique et sociale du
territoire concerné nous souhaitons donc
soit le retrait soit mettre un avis
défavorable à cet amendement bien je
vais consulter le gouvernement
oui avis défavorable aussi monsieur le
Président mais c'est un c'est un
amendement
important et et je dirais intelligent
donc je souhaiterais plutôt qu'il soit
retiré qui soit retiré pour pas émettre
un avis défavorable en effet Monsieur
monsieur le sénateur le le périmètre le
périmètre ça durera peut-être pas tout
long temps hein le le périmètre des
intercommunalités est est plus évolutif
que celui des circonscriptions de
cantonal il est en effet déterminé par
un simple arrêté
préfectoral tandis que tandis que celui
des circonscriptions cantonelles est par
décret en Conseil d'État hein donc la
délimitation des des cantons en plus
devra respecter les limites on l'a dit
dans le débat mais il faut le redire
devra respecter les limites des
circonscriptions législatives qui sont
elles fixées par la loi la loi que vous
avez voté ou pas voté mais elle a été
votée par le Parlement il y a quelques
semaines donc votre proposition monsieur
le sénateur aboutirait donc à rendre
moins stable dans le temps les les
limites des des cantons et par par
ailleurs en terme de ce qu'on appelle la
hiérarchie des des normes que vous
connaissez bien une modification une
modification de de limite intercommunale
par arrêté préfectoral imposerait de
modifier les les cantons par décret en
Conseil d'État et les circonscriptions
législatives par une loi ce qui vous en
conviendrait vous qui êtes un grand
juriste n'est pas très cohérent voilà
Monsieur Bard vous avez la
parole j'ai bien compris qu'il était
sage de retirer un amendement
intelligent au point d'incohérence où
nous sommes je vais donc suivre
cet excellent conseil ce qui sera faire
preuve
d'intelligence voilà qui est bien
dit bien alors mes chers collègues
maintenant nous avons 10 amendements ou
sousamendements qui vont faire l'objet
d'une discussion commune avant l'article
1er AA j'appelle le
551 de Monsieur
Abou monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministr ministre mes chers collègues le
21 janvier dernier notre groupe a
proposé au Sénat de fixer ce que le
rapporteur courtois avait défini comme
le cadre légitime de la réflexion
portant sur le mode d'élection des
conseillers
territoriaux adopté avec l'avis
favorable de la commission l'article 1er
a visait à préciser les grands principes
sur lesquels l'élection des conseillers
territoriaux doit être fondé afin
d'apporter les garanties nécessaires en
terme de représentation territoriale de
représentation démographique
d'expression pluraliste et de parité
pour reprendre encore une fois votre
définition monsieur le rapporteur cet
article a été modifié à l'Assemblée
nationale pour prévoir un mode de
scrutin nominal majoritaire à deux tours
puis supprimer en commission des lois au
Sénat avant que nous n'examinions les
propositions relatives aux modalités
d'élection des conseillers territoriaux
nous proposons donc au Sénat de rétablir
le cadre légitime de la réflexion en
revenant à la rédaction initiale de
l'article 1er a cet article fixe quatre
principes fondamentaux le premier
principe c'est la représentation des
territoires nous y sommes tous
profondément attachés et nous pensons
qu'une dose importante de scrutin un
nominal est la meilleure façon de la
garantir le second principe qui n'est
pas moins vrai c'est la représentation
des populations ce même 21 janvier vous
l'avez dit monsieur le ministre
ce le conseiller territorial assure la
représentation des citoyens avant celle
des
territoires le troisième principe c'est
le respect du pluralisme là encore mes
ch mes chers collègues je pense que nous
tous ici parce que nous sommes des élus
attachés aux valeurs de notre démocratie
nous y sommes profondément attachés nous
ne sommes pas les seuls le 20 octobre
dernier le président de la République
affirmaé lui aussi que le pluralisme des
idées des politiques justifie que l'on
réserve une place aux différents
courants de pensée fusent-il minoritair
dans les conseils généraux et régionaux
mes chers collègues pour donner vie à ce
principe il faut prévoir une dose de
proportionnelle une dose proportionnelle
ce n'est pas un dogme c'est la meilleure
façon pour garantir le respect du
pluralisme le 4è principe fondamental
lui aussi inscrit à l'article 1er de la
Constitution c'est la parité favoriser
l'égal accès des femmes et des hommes au
mandats électifs est une exigence
constitutionnelle politique et morale là
encore je pense que sur tous les bancs
sur tous nos bancs nous y sommes
profondément attachés voilà mes chers
collègues le cadre légitime de la
réflexion une contribution importante du
Sénat que vous nous propose nous vous
proposons de
rétablir je vous
remercie madame Blandin vous nous
présentez le 269 vecpier vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
euh contrairement à l'orateur précédent
nous ne souhaitons pas sénateur vert que
soit créé le mandat de conseiller
territorial nous souhaitons garder
l'exemplarité de la proportionnelle dans
les régions et nous souhaitons même que
le département
évolue nous avons entendu la semaine
dernière dans la bouche du ministre une
réponse qui n'est pas acceptable à un
amendement du groupe CRC sur la parité
je le cite la mise en œuvre dans le mode
de scrutin de la parité pose des
problèmes
techniques cette réponse n'est pas
correcte on ne commence pas en politique
par la
technique on commence en politique par
dire les valeurs le projet le but que
l'on poursuit et après on construit un
mode électoral adéquate alors pour les
département une large majorité souhaite
une assemblée gouvernable mais aussi la
diversité politique mais aussi la parité
mais aussi une représentation conservée
du territoire et bien cet amendement
vous donne une audacieuse solution il
s'inspire d'un scrutin insttutieux
utilisé dans plusieurs pays
d'Europe chaque électeur dispose de deux
voies une pour désigner son élu préféré
local une pour choisir sur liste son
parti préféré la première voix est gérée
pour un scrutin
uninominal la seconde détermine à la
proportionnelle une partie de
l'échiquier de l'assemblée
départementale ainsi nous satisferions
les quatre critères que nous nous sommes
donnés chaque élu aurait la légitimité
du scrutin universel et ce n'est pas ici
au Sénat où cohabitent des élus issus de
scrutins uninominaux et des élus issus
de scrutin à la proportionnelle que vous
pourrez dire que cela pose
problème je vous remercie le 553 c'est
toujours le président à bout c'est
Monsieur Moré qui est le présente pour
le groupe deunion centriste
oui président à vous à
vous présenter monsieur le Président
Monsieur les ministres mes chers
collègues comme je vous l'indiquer il y
a un instant cet amendement vise à
prévoir pour l'élection des conseillers
territoriaux à mode de scrutin mixte
nous vous proposons delire 80 % des
conseillers territoriaux au scrutin un
nominal majoritaire à deux tours dans le
cadre du canton et cadre département et
20 % d'entre eux au scrutin
proportionnel dans le cadre du
département pour qu'elle est une
incidence même limitée sur la
composition des conseils généraux et
régionaux nous vous proposons une
proportionnelle correctrice avec
seulement 20 % de conseiller élus à la
proportionnelle c'est une nécessité cela
a été mesuré vérifié con
et les simulations jointes au projet de
loi numéro 61 ne laissent aucun doute
sur ce point prévoir 20 % de
proportionnelle non correctrice n'a
quasiment aucun effet sur le pluralisme
des assemblées la proportionnelle
correctrice que nous vous proposons
permettra de corriger les distorsions de
représentation du au scrutin
uninominal concrètement les 20 % de
sièges à pourvoir la proportionnelle
seront octroyés aux listes qui n'ont pas
obtenu autant de sièges au scrutinom
qu'elle aurait reçu au scrutin
proportionnel cette proposition est la
meilleure manière d'assurer la
représentation des territoires et des
population tout en respectant le
pluralisme des opinions elle vise donc à
appliquer concrètement le respect de
trois des quatre principes fondamentaux
que nous défendons depuis le début de
l'examen de ce texte parce qu'elle
comporte une dose de proportionnelle au
scrutin de liste cette proposition
permettrait également de favoriser la
parité mais nous ne prétendons pas qu'un
mode de scrutin mixte suffirait à lui
seul à satisfaire à cette obligation ce
4è principe auquel nous sommes fermement
attachés mérite d'être traité
spécifiquement c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous vous proposerons également
un dispositif véritablement incitatif
afin de promouvoir l'égal accès des
femmes et des hommes au mondat au mandat
de conseiller
territorial merci Madame Dini vous nous
présentez le
562 s'il vous plaît merci monsieur le
Président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues cet amendement vise à
favoriser la parité tel que le stipule
l'article 1 de la Constitution et ceci
même dans le scrutin unominal il propose
que le bulletin de vote porte le nom de
deux personnes de sexes différents que
l'électeur devra classé celui ou celle
qui remportera le plus de première place
sera le titulaire et l'autre le
suppléant si ce scrutin n'aboutit pas
obligatoirement à la parité il offre aux
électeurs le choix réel entre une une
femme et un homme pour le représenter au
sein des instances élues et ici pour les
conseillers territoriaux techniquement
il y a aucun empêchement pour le mettre
en œuvre les réticences ne peuvent venir
que de la crainte des candidats sortants
qui souhaitent se représenter et qui
sont dans les conseils généraux pour 97
% des hommes craintte de se retrouver en
concurrence directe avec une femme je je
vous invite mes chers collègues à
montrer votre esprit d'avant-garde en
adoptant cet
amendement merci maintenant le j'appelle
le
576 rectifié du gouvernement
oui monsieur le Président le le
gouvernement propose au au Sénat par le
présent amendement de retenir comme l'a
fait la l'Assemblée nationale en
première lecture le mode de scrutin
uninominal majoritaire à deux tours pour
l'élection à partir de 2014 des
conseiller territoriaux je reviens
succintement non pas sur l'évolution et
la procédure qui nous ont conduit à ce
choix mais sur les raisons fondamentales
je dirais qui nous poussent à vous le
proposer il s'agit d'abord d'un d'un
système électoral connu et apprécié des
français appliqué aujourd'hui pour
l'élection des députés comme pour celle
des conseillers généraux deuxièmement il
est il est approuvé par une grande
majorité de formation politique de la
majorité comme de l'opposition qui ne
l'ont jamais mis en cause pour les
élections cantonales il est apprécié et
je rappelle d'ailleurs que le le rapport
d'information Moré Colomba le numéro 509
qui a été publié euh très très récemment
euh retient retient ce mote de scrutin
comme étant le meilleur et le plus
proche des électeurs enfin il permet à
la fois de maintenir une représentation
des territoires au sein des futures
assemblées départementales et régional
et de garantir et de garantir
l'existence d'une majorité stable c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement demande à votre
Haute assemblée de bien vouloir adopter
le présent
amendement merci alors j'ai un
sousamendement
rectifié c'est pas une femme qui
monsieur Baudin bon je cherch madame
André c'est Monsieur bin qui
m'apparaî
merci je m'exprime monsieur le Président
en effet je m'exprime au nom de Madame
André qui n'a pas pu être là ce soir la
délégation au droits des femmes s'est
évidemment préoccupé du respect de la
parité
elle rappelle que la loi doit favoriser
l'égal accès des hommes et des femmes au
mandat
électif c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne serait
donc accepté que la loi défavorise cet
égal accès
c'est le sens du sous-amendement qui
vous est proposé ici par Madame
André présidente de la délégation du
droit des femmes et signé par des
membres de cette délégation tout groupe
politique confondu et qui demande un
scrutin majoritaire à de Tours par binô
compris composé de deux candidats de
sexes
différents le président Collin vous nous
présentez le 600 s'il vous plaît sous
amendement 600
oui monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres mes chers
collègues l'ensemble des membres de mon
groupe et moi-même nous avons choisi de
déposer ce sous-amendement 600 pour être
en cohérence avec les positions défendu
par mon groupe depuis le début de la
discussion de ce projet de loi et plus
exactement depuis sa première lecture
car chacun se souvient qu'en première
lecture nos collègues du groupe
centriste avaient fait adopter un
amendement si 685 prévoyant que le
conseiller territorial serait élu sur
une base mixte mêlant scrutin uninominal
et scrutin proportionnel nous étions
alors dans la quessence même du
compromis une majorité des membres de
mon groupe fut et demeure en toute
hypothèse opposée à la création du
conseiller
territorial mais nous avions alors
déposé un sous-amendement à l'amend du
président abour pour préciser que le
conseiller territorial serait
exclusivement élu au scrutin uninominal
majoritaire à deux tours conformément à
une tradition républicaine on nous
opposa alors avec force comme à tous les
parlementaires de l'opposition
d'ailleurs l'argument selon lequel les
modalités d'élection du conseill
territorial feraient l'objet d'un autre
projet de loi et que nous étions ainsi
en avance sur le calendrier du
gouvernement puis on nous objecta que
notre sous-amendement contrevenait tout
simplement au compromis conclus entre le
groupe centriste et le gouvernement
notre proposition fut ainsi écartée sans
ménagement sur l'ensemble des bandes de
cet hémicycle or il semble que nous
avions raison avant tout le monde
puisque qu'elle n fut pas notre surprise
de découvrir qu'en première lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
avait introduit par voie d'amendement un
article 1ier à en faveur d'un scrutin
uninominal majoritaire à de tours comme
par enchantement tous les raisonnements
nous renvoyant indéfiniment à un texte
ultérieur avait subitement disparu cela
revenait d'abord à laisser le Sénat
dépouiller de sa fonction première de
représentation des collectivités cela
revenait surtout à violer l'esprit même
de la Constitution comme l'a démontré
mon excellent collègue et ami Jacques
mard lors de la de notre motion
d'exception d'irrecevabilité et
d'ailleurs notre commission des lois ne
s'y est pas trompée en supprimant cet
article article que le gouvernement nous
propose désormais de réintroduire après
nous avoir expliqué en première lecture
qu'il n'y avait pas sa place forcez donc
de constater que cela devient un peu
complexe pour un esprit logique pour un
esprit pragmatique et plein de bon sens
comme celui des membres de mon groupe
qui aime à se position librement et
indépendamment des clivages partisans
voilà qu'on nous explique que ce qui
n'était pas possible en première lecture
au Sénat le devient en 2uxème lecture
quand nous commencions à être convaincus
par les arguments de la première lecture
à savoir queun notre projet de loi le
texte 61 en l'occurrence aurait pour
objet spécifique le seul mode de scrutin
du conseiller territorial alors mes
chers collègues à ce stade du débat et
d'une discussion de plus en plus
hubuesque pour ne pas dire parfois
absurde la totalité des membres de RDSE
a fait le choix de cigner et de déposer
ce sous-amendement qui a pour objet
d'abaisser à 8 % le seuil des inscrits
nécessaires pour se maintenir au second
tour d'élection de conseiller
territorial contre les 12 et demi % dans
le texte qui nous est revenu je conclus
à l'Assemblée nationale nous estimons
essentiel pour notre démocratie de
faciliter l'expression du pluralisme des
opinions qui fait la richesse de notre
République tel est le S de cet
amendement merci Madame Blandin vous
dépensez vous défendez le 266 vous avez
la parole je ne dépense rien monsieur le
Président on va essayer de faire des
économies et on va prendre les deux
mêmes modes de scrutin pour la région et
pour le département la France était déjà
regardée par les Européens avec
curiosité en raison d'archaïsme durable
le cumule l'empignement des niveaux
l'érosion de l'autonomie fiscale des
collectivités la faible place faite aux
femmes et voici qu'une réforme envisage
de tourner le dos à l'évolution
démocratique historique des États et des
régions d'Europe et fait table race de
l'intelligence de la
proportionnelle vous aviez même envisagé
un scrutin uninominal à un tour mais
revenons encore plus en arrière pourquoi
pas des duchés avec transmission
héréditaire du pouvoir le peuple s'y
retrouverez non seulement au niveau du
territoire mais au niveau de la famille
qui le gouverne notre amendement vous
propose un mode de scrutin respectueux
de la diversité et seul à même de
garantir la parité oh nous avons
anticiper vos arguments sur la stabilité
il y a une sorte de prime majoritaire
alors vous allez brandir la
représentation des territoires mais on
va faire confiance au partis pour y
veiller vous vous nous dites bien que
l'on peut faire confiance au partis
politiques pour qu'il y ait des femmes
et puis soyons honnêtes la
représentation du territoire que vous
proposez est toute symbolique elle est
davantage descendante topd dit-on à
Bruxelles
qu'ascendante bottom up votre conseiller
territorial sera un élu surchargé
condamné au déplacement il faudrait
faire son bil carbone la
multireprésentation ne sera pas synonyme
de
multicompétences tirailler entre
politique sociale développement
économique culture tourisme
environnement il ne saura plus comme dit
l'expression populaire où il habite
demandez donc aux acteurs locaux
chercheurs au patron de PME s'il est
facile d'avoir un rendez-vous auprès du
conseiller départemental au régionale et
ben dites-lui que maintenant c'est la
même personne avec le double emploi du
temps et qu'en plus
idéologiquement les assemblées sont
toutes bleu et toutes rose ou bien
demain toutes orange et toute verte ou
bien après-demain toute bleue et toute
rouge et bien je ne me
réjouirai d'aucun scénario binaire la
démocratie c'est la juste
représentation de chacun à commencé par
51 % de femmes majoritaires dans le
genre humain et spolié par le matchisme
des scrutins uninominaux pour les
écologistes la démocratie c'est la
proportionnelle qui met en confrontation
des projets de société et pas des
territoires merci le
309 vous avez la parole monsieur
Guillaume non c'est l'autre il marche
pas bien celui-là merci monsieur le
Président monessieurs les ministres mais
le MIR est éteint mes chers collègues
euh cet amendement va dans la la logique
de ce que nous défendons depuis depuis
le début de la loi nous sommes opposés
aux conseillers territoriaux et nous
voulons bien un élu régional et un élu
départemental mais il faut bien avancer
et cet amendement 309 est un am de un
amendement de de logique afin d'éviter
une certaine concurrence entre les
cantons et les intercommunalités en
effet le fait intercommunal prend de
plus en plus plus de de place dans la
société d'ailleurs le gouvernement a
pris la décision de mettre une carte
intercommunale qui va sur l'ensemble du
territoire national et il nous semble
que le le périmètre des
intercommunalités doit correspondre au
périmètre des circonscription cantonnale
que qui serait découpé dans une grande
dans une grande intercommunalité il peut
y avoir plusieurs cantons plusieurs
intercommunalités peuvent être regoupé
dans un seul canton mais en aucun cas
une communauté de communes une
intercommunalité un EPCI pourra être
découpé se retrouver dans plusieurs dans
plusieurs cantons c'est vraiment euh
afin d'éviter une certaine concurrence
entre le fait inter communautaire et le
fait cantonnal je vous remercie merci
Monsieur guum Madame Blandin le dernier
amendement 267 s'il vous plaît très
rapidement monsieur le Président cet
amendement
267 n'a qu'un but favoriser la
lisibilité dans les scrutins régionaux
en permettant à l'avenir qu'une seule
liste puisse se présenter pour
l'ensemble de chaque région et non plus
une par département ce qui rend
aujourd'hui relativement complexe le
scrutin et nuit à la dynamique régionale
à l'heure de l'Union européenne la
région c'est le lieu propiss au
déploiement des politiques publiques qui
composent le dynamisme des territoires
il y aurait un intérêt simplement
démocratique à rendre plus lisible pour
les électeurs ce scrutin plus
compréhensible les élus seraient
reconnus la collectivité susciterait un
degré plus important d'adhésion si la
logique de cette réforme messieurs les
ministres est de faire émerger des
régions fortes comme vous l'avez dit des
pôles fédérateurs et dynamique à la
hauteur de nos pays- voisins alors la
question de leur gouvernance et donc de
leur compréhension est un enjeu
primordial je vous remercie je vais
demander l'avis du rapporteur non mais
attendez attendez monsieur le Président
monsieurs les ministres sur le premier
amendement de 551 présenté par Monsieur
Abou monsieur Abou effectivement a
expliqué l'historique de l'opération et
je ne peux que effectivement confirmer
les propos de Monsieur Abou
puisqueeffectivement en première lecture
le Sénat a adopté un système système qui
a été profondément modifié par
l'Assemblée nationale ce qui a conduit
la commission des lois lors de sa
première séance à supprimé les articles
qui avaient été adoptés par l'Assemblée
nationale cela est tout tout à fait vrai
au titre des amendements extérieurs la
commission des lois a adopté
l'amendement que nous trouverons un peu
plus tard de de présenté par le
gouvernement et qui dit que le scrutin
sera uni nominal à deux tours à partir
de ce moment-là en tant que rapporteur
et au nom de la commission des lois je
ne peux donc que mettre un avis
défavorable à cet amendement 551
puisqu'il est contraire à ce qu'a
accepté la commission des lois lors de
sa deuxè
lecture l'amendement
269 cet amendement vise à mettre en
place un mode de scrutin miiste qu'on
appelle à l'allemande pour l'élection
des conseillers territoriaux il est donc
contraire à la position de la Commission
qui est je vous le rappelle une nominale
à deux tours le
553 de Monsieur Abou reprend
effectivement le mode de scrutin mixte à
l'allemande avec cette fois deux
bulletins
distinctes contraire à la position de la
Commission les conseillers territoriaux
sont élus sur un mode de scrittin une
nominal majoritaire à deux tours donc ce
n'est pas compatible avec la proposition
de Monsieur Abou l'amendement 500 162
présenté par Madame Dini et Monsieur
Abou cet amendement met en place un mode
de chtin miste où 80 % des conseillers
territoriaux seront élus au scrutin
majoritaire à de Tours selon un système
de binôme paritaire où il reviendra à
l'électeur de choisir lequel des deux
candidats devra être titulaire et lequel
devra être
suppléant c'est assez complexe quand
même comme système c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire 20 % des conseillers
territoriaux seraient élu au scrutin de
liste c'est naturellement là aussi
malheureusement contraire à la position
de la
Commission l'amendement 576 du
gouvernement a été examiné par la
commission des lois il y a eu d'ailleurs
une longue discussion
et à l'essue de cette discussion après
un vote cet amendement a été adopté par
la commission des lois et donc institut
a mise en place d'un scrutin un nominal
majoritaire à deux tours pour les
élections des conseillers territoriaux
on peut souligner que les élus locaux
étaient attachés à ce mode de scrutin
qui en outre connu et apprécié par les
électeurs et la Commission a également
considéré qu'il donnerait au conseillers
territoriauxx une assise locale
forte l'amendement numéro
581 sousamendement identique dans ses
effets dans son objet à un amendement
déposé par Madame André et plusieurs de
ses collègues lors de l'établissement du
texte de la commission ce
sous-amendement met en place un binôme
paritaire pour l'élection des
conseillers territoriaux en d'autres
termes mes chers j'appelle votre
attention sur cette disposition ce ne
serait pas un candidat mais deux
candidats de sexe opposés qui se
présenteraient aux élections
territoriales dans un territoire unique
et toujours dans le cadre d'un scrutin
nominal majoritaire à deux tours ces
deux candidats une fois élus seraient
tous les deux des conseillers
territoriaux à part entière c'est la
différence avec le système proposé par
Madame Dini que j'ai exposé tout à
l'heure dans lequel un binôme se
présente mais où les électeurs
choisissent qui de la femme ou de
l'homme sera titulaire ou suppléant le
but de ce sousam c'est à fait vrai
naturellement de favoriser la parité
toutefois la commission des lois est
opposée à ce système qui mènerait s'il
était adopté et j'appelle votre
attention sur ce sujet à diviser par de
le nombre de territoires et donc à créé
des super super cantons trop larg pour
que les électeurs réellement un lien
avec leurs élus donc demande de retrait
ou un avis
territorial l'amendement numéro 600
l'amendement numéro 600 a pour but de à
ramener le taux pour se présenter au 2è
tour à 8
%. ayant été déposé au cours de la
journée naturellement il a pas pu être
examiné par la commission des lois aussi
à titre personnel j'attendrai d'avoir
l'avis du Gouvernement sur cette
disposition
266 cet amendement réforme le mode de
scrutin pour l'élection des conseillers
généraux il est sans lien avec le
présent texte et d'ailleurs je tiens à
dire qu'il avait déjà reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission en première
lecture l'amendement
309 opposition de la Commission à l' à
l'appellation conseiller départementaux
soit s'appelle conseillers territoriaux
il n'est d'ailleurs pas judicieux de
tenir compte des limites des
intercommunalités qui peuvent être
modifié au cours du temps la notion de
bassin de vie qui soutend les
délimitations prévues par l'article 1er
AA est de ce point de vue beaucoup plus
satisfaisante enfin l'amendement 267 cet
amendement réforme le mode actuel de
scrutin pour l'élection des conseillers
régionaux il est donc sans lien avec le
présent texte avis
défavorable je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre votre avis sur ces 10
amendements et sur
amendement pas
é bon je vous remercie
beaucoup et merci monsieur le Président
de me donner la
parole je
voudrais je voudrais répondre à
l'ensemble des auteurs des amendements
qu's ont
étéur ministre vous avez seul la parole
maises commencer un dialogue avec Madame
Gouro et je voudrais pas interrompre ce
dialogue sement premierur
d'avenir bon écoutez pas d'aparté
monsieur le ministre
allez-y donc sur sur le premier
amendement numéro 551 qui qui reprend en
quelque sorte ce qui avait été voté en
première lecture par Sénat
m'amène très naturellement à à à
expliquer une nouvelle fois l'histoire
depuis ce vote je rappelle qu'au moment
du vote le gouvernement n'avait pas cru
devoir donner un avis défavorable c'est
les termes mêmes qui ont été employés
par le ministre qui était au ban c'était
moi donc je m'en souviens fort bien
c'est dans cet état que l'affaire s'est
présentée devant le Sénat était voté par
le Sénat et qu ensuite l'Assemblée
nationale a été
saisie le gouvernement avait déposé un
projet de loi électorale il faut bien
reconnaître que ce projet n'a pas
reconnu recueilli un succès très
important on peut même dire qu'il a été
soutenu par personne à peu près à part
le
gouvernement ce qui est
non monsieur Colomba je ne manquerai pas
de vous citer dans quelques instants
donc vous aurez l'occasion de répondre
mais mais il est vrai que les paroles
engagent et les écrit plus encore donc
on s'en tiendra là le gouvernement après
les élections régionales le Premier
ministre a organisé une concertation une
consultation de la plus de tous les
partis politiques présent au Parlement à
certain nombre n'ont pas répondu en
disant les choses sont déjà
décidées c'est ce qui a
été écrit par certain d'autres ont
indiqué qu'ils étaient pour le scrutin
majoritaire uninominal à de Tours et
d'autres enfin ont pas exprimé de
position très clair devant d'autres ont
exprimé
oralement des positions plutôt en faveur
d'un scrutin mixte et d'autres n'ont pas
répondu du tout devant cette
consultation organisée par le Premier
ministre et devant les demandes émanant
d'un certain nombre de parlementaires le
gouvernement a choisi
à la fois de répondre immédiatement aux
demandes qui ont été présentées
d'inclure dès ce projet de loi un mode
d'élection des conseillers territoriaux
et je rappelle que le conseiller
territorial a été voté par les deux
Chambres désormais
et bien entendu dès lors qu'il
introduisait le mode d'élection dans la
loi institutionnel et bien le
gouvernement a choisi le mode de scrutin
majoritaire uninominal à à deux tour
pour plusieurs raisons qui sont
excellemment rapporté page 136 du
rapport qui a été fait par la délégation
du Sénat aux collectivités territoriales
et Don les auteurs sont monsieur MAEt et
Monsieur Colomba moi j'avoue que c'est
un excellent rapport je dis pas que tel
ou tel sénateur soutient tel ou tel mode
de scrutin je dis simplement que les
analyses qui sont dans ce rapport sont
excellentes et que replace bien la
question et le problème et que si on
considère qu'il s'agit en matière
d'élection euh d'assemblée
locale bien d'avoir un mode de scrutin
qui a une capacité à dégager des
majorités stables et à permettre la
représentation du territoire c'est quand
même ce que l'on recherche lorsque l'on
met en œuvre un mode de scrutin destiné
à élir les membres des assemblées
locales si ce sont ces deux critères qui
sont les deux principaux il est évident
que comme cela a été écrit le scrutin
majoritaire uninominal à deux tours est
le mieux placé donc le gouvernement a
fait ce choix l'Assemblée nationale l'a
fait également et le gouvernement a
soutenu ce qui a été voté par
l'Assemblée nationale il n'a pas la
possibilité ni l'envie de changer sa
position elle est désormais connue et
établie et il veut simplement essayer de
persuader la Haute Assemblée que ce mode
de scrutin familia français qui est
utilisé pour l'élection des conseillers
généraux aujourd'hui est un bon système
est un bon système et qui convient de le
reprendre c'est ce qui fait que le
Gouvernement partage la position de la
Commission qu'il est défavorable à
l'amendement 551 à l'amendement
269 à l'amendement 553 moi je voudrais
dire un mot sur les scrutin mixte je
dois dire que à titre personnel moi je
suis plutôt intéressé par les scrutin
mixte sur le plan
intellectuel c'est quelque chose qui
paraît intéressant parce que on se dit
la société complexe mérite un système
complexe pour représenter sa complexité
et c'est vrai que le scrutin mixte peut
aller vers meilleur type de
représentation la plus exacte possible
mais il s'agit il s'agit d'avoir euh il
s'agit de d'élire des membres
d'assemblée territorial à faible
effectif pour les département et avoir
un scru mixte lorsqu'on a un faible
effectif
20 élus 25 élus 30 élus 50 élus la
partie proportionnelle 20 % telle
qu'elle est proposé a d'abord pour
premier premier pardon d'abord pour
premère conséquence de réduire la
représentation territoriale puisqu'il y
a moins de cantons de territoire
représenté en tant que tel et un certain
nombre de
représentation des idéologies donc ça
c'est la première conséquence et en plus
ça porte sur des très petits nombres 3 7
et même si l'on
déclare que l'on cherche une
proportionnelle correctrice j'avoue que
ça c'est un terme générique dont je
comprends mal l'utilisation dès lors
qu'on a deux bulletins si on a deux
bulletins on a deux scrutins et on peut
pas dire les voies obtenues au prier
scrutin ne compons pas pour le deè
scrutin sinon ça ne marche pas parce que
c'est la liberté de l'électeur s'il a de
bulletins de les utiliser comme il veut
et il peut très bien voter pour un
candidat du la formation a avec son
premier bulletin au scrutin majoritaire
et pour le parti a avec sa voix
proportionnelle si on veut une
proportionnelle correctrice il y a
obligatoirement un seul bultin et pas
deux avec deux bulletins elle ne peut
pas être correctrice parce qu'il y a
deux scrutins juste
àosés mais pas correctrice parce que en
Allemagne monsieur van lorenberg puisque
vous m'interrompez je vais vous répondre
avec le plus de gentillesse possible en
Allemagne monsieur van lurenberg il y a
une petite particularité que vous
oubliez toujours de rappeler c'est que
le nombre de dép mais que vous
connaissiez par cur beaucoup de choses
je n'en dis conviens pas mais vous
pouvez me laisser répondre et aller
jusqu'au bout je rappelle qu'en
Allemagne le nombre de députés n'est pas
fixé à l'avance et que on peut aller
au-delà et que ce n'est pas possible
dans le système du conseiller
territorial puisqu'il y a un tableau des
effectifs qui fixe strict au sensus le
nombre d'élus à la fois pour les
conseillers territoriaux et par
département pour tenir compte du critère
démographique qui est le critère
essentiel en terme de démocratie donc
voilà pour le 553 qui cond le
gouvernement à donné un avis défavorable
pour le numéro 562 c'est l'amendement de
Madame DIN
m sa parfaitement que bien sûr son
amendement est subtile
mais il est il est bien sûr subtile mais
il a un petit
problème il a il a un petit problème qui
est tout simple c'est que on nous dit
voilà il y a une équipe de candidats qui
vient se présenter un homme et une femme
et on saura qu'à la fin qui est le
titulaire qui est le suppléant
simplement il faut quand même faire
attention au fait que le principe
d'intelligibilité de la loi qui est un
principe constitutionnel prévoit que il
faut bien sûr que chacun comprenne bien
ce qu'il fait et qu'on peut avoir
envie c'est avec le système d' c'est
assez compliqué mais il faut bien
comprendre madame gourau que on peut
avoir envie de
voir le candidat femme titulaire vote
pour l'équipe femme titulaire homme
suppléent puis l'électeur d'à côté il
peut avoir l'envie contraire et bien
mais mais ça va pas du tout parce que
s'il a gagné et bien celui qui voulait
la femme titulaire il aurait voté
autrement et et donc ce principe
d'intelligibilité de la loi qui est un
principe constitutionnel nous conduit
malheureusement à donner un avis des
favorable à cet excellent amendement
l'amendement 576 a été excellemment
présenté par Monsieur le Ministre marlex
c'est la position du gouvernement donc
je n'ai rien à
ajouter sur le sous amendement de Madame
André je partage l'avis de la commission
et je donne un avis défavorable sur
l'amendement 600 euh j'ai bien compris
que c'était là un sujet très important
l'Assemblée nationale a voté euh un
seuil de 12,5i % aujourd'hui dans la loi
ce sont 10 % des inscrits euh pour les
cantonales et la Commission a voté 12
pardon la commission oui a voté 12,5 %.
donne un avis défavorable à cet
amendement que nous n'avons pas eu le
temps d'étudier complètement à ce jour
puisqu'il vient de nous arriver il y a 1
minute 30 euh pour ce qui est de
l'amendement
266 avis défavorable pour les motifs que
j'ai indiqué de la même façon euh
pour l'amendement numéro 309 qui reprend
l'amendement du Président collinquel on
a déjà répondu quant à la à l'amendement
numéro
267 et bien nous n'avons nous pouvons
pas donner un avis favorable parce que
s'il y avait que 50
% des élus des conseillers territoriaux
qui puissent siéger à la région on
entrerait dans un autre système et
notamment il faudrait savoir comment ces
élus viennent à la région si c'est par
tirage au sur ou par élection des autres
conseillers territoriaux si c'était dans
ce cas-là on serait plus avec une région
collectivité territoriale mais avec une
région EPCI ce que nous ne voulons pas
donc avis
défavorable le Sénat a donc rejeté ce
mode d'élection des conseillers
territoriaux le gouvernement souhaité
une élection au scrutin uninominal à
deux tours mais les centristes clé du
scrutin ici au Sénat souhaiter
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle l'examen de la réforme
des collectivités territoriales se
poursuit cet après-midi au Sénat vous
pourrez suivre cette séance sur notre
antenne à partir de 16h30 très bonne
journée